y lo pusimos todo en un cubo
y dijimos: "Los hombres y las mujeres son diferentes".
Nos acostumbramos y nunca más lo desafiamos,
y es fascinante para mí,
y por fascinante quiero decir un poco insensato,
que aún hablamos de esto como un segmento
cuando es más como un remanente.
De hecho, no llego a esta conclusión a la ligera.
Tenemos suficientes datos para sugerir que el género no es el mejor lugar
para que comiencen a diseñar y orientar sus marcas.
E incluso iría un paso más allá:
a menos que estén trabajando en una categoría de producto muy específica
cualquier otra cosa que
estén hipotetizando sobre su consumidor ahora mismo
va a ser más útil que el género.
No nos preparamos para sacar esta conclusión específicamente.
La encontramos.
Como consultores, nuestro trabajo es ir con nuestros clientes
y entender sus negocios
y tratar de ayudarlos a encontrar espacios donde sus marcas crezcan.
Creemos que si desean encontrar un crecimiento disruptivo en el mercado,
debe dirigirse al consumidor
y tener una visión muy agnóstica del consumidor.
Tienen que ir y mirarlos desde cero,
quitarse todos los prejuicios y segmentos que creían importantes,
solo echen un ojo para ver dónde está el crecimiento.
Y nos construimos un algoritmo precisamente para eso.
Imaginen que tenemos a una persona
y sabemos que una persona hace una elección
sobre un producto o servicio,
y de esa persona, puedo conocer su género, por supuesto,
otros datos demográficos, dónde viven, sus ingresos, y otras cosas.
Sé el contexto donde esta persona está tomando una decisión,
dónde están, con quién están.
la energía, cualquier cosa,
y también puedo poner otras cosas en la mezcla.
Puedo conocer sus opiniones,
cómo se sienten sobre la categoría
y sus comportamientos.
Si imaginan que una persona es esta gran bases de datos...
Voy a simplificar la ciencia aquí
pero básicamente construimos un algoritmo para torneos estadísticos.
Un torneo estadístico es como preguntar a estos grandes datos:
"A ver, datos, con todo lo que conoces de los consumidores en este momento,
¿qué es lo más útil que necesito saber
que me daría más información sobre lo que necesitan los consumidores?".
Así que el torneo va a tener ganadores y perdedores.
Los ganadores son esas variables, esas dimensiones,
que de hecho le enseñan mucho sobre su consumidor,
que si saben eso, saben lo que necesitan.
Y hay variables perdedoras que no son tan prácticas,
y esto importa, porque en un mundo de recursos limitados,
no querrá desperdiciarlos en personas que tienen las mismas necesidades.
Entonces, ¿por qué tratarlos diferente?
Ya sé que el suspenso no los está matando
porque ya les dije cuál es el resultado,
pero lo que descubrimos con el tiempo
después de 200 proyectos por el mundo cubriendo 20 países o más
-en esencia, organizamos alrededor de 100 000 de estos torneos-
no nos sorprende notar que el género rara vez es lo más predictivo
para entender las necesidades del consumidor.
De 100 000 torneos,
el género solo apareció como variable ganadora
en aproximadamente el 5 %.
Y esto es cierto en todo el mundo.
Cuando lo hicimos en lugares donde los roles de género tradicionales
están un poco más pronunciados,
las conclusiones fueron exactamente las mismas.
El género era importante en un poco más que el 5 %
pero no en lo material.
Dejemos que esa idea cale.
No importa cómo vean a un consumidor,
lo más probable es que cualquier otra cosa sea más interesante que el género.
Probablemente hay algo más importante que necesitan saber sobre ellos,
y lo están distrayendo porque están haciendo todo basado en el género.
Y es por eso que están dejando dinero sobre la mesa.
El género es fácil.
Es fácil diseñar anuncios basados en género,
es fácil dirigirse a personas en línea o en televisión en función del género.
Pero al final, no es de donde vendrá el crecimiento más importante.
En una empresa de alimentos, por ejemplo, es mucho más interesante para Uds.
saber dónde come la gente, con quién comen,
si están muy orientados nutricionalmente.
Todas esas cosas son significativamente más poderosas e útiles
que saber si la persona es un hombre o una mujer.
Y eso importa, por supuesto,
porque si estás poniendo en práctica un presupuesto limitado,
entonces es mejor crear soluciones para ocasiones diferentes
que dirigirse a las mujeres o a los hombres.
Otro ejemplo son las bebidas alcohólicas.
El 35 % a 40 % del consumo de bebidas alcohólicas
en todo el mundo proviene de las mujeres
pero "las mujeres no beben cerveza"
son las cosas que típicamente oímos.
Cuando un hombre y una mujer están, en su mayor parte, en un mismo lugar
las necesidades emocionales y funcionales en ese momento
son muy similares.
Solo hay una excepción, por cierto,
y la excepción existe,
si tienen a un hombre y una mujer
en una cita,
el hombre trata de impresionar a la mujer
y la mujer trata de conectar con el hombre,
entonces habrá un poco de tensión,
pero es importante saberlo.
Les tomará unas cuantas citas.
Las instituciones financieras: son algo donde hemos escuchado mucho
sobre la diferencia entre hombres y mujeres,
pero en realidad hablar sobre estas diferencias
los distrae de lo que está bajo la superficie.
Lo simplificamos como: "las mujeres no quieren invertir",
"ellas odian administrar su dinero",
"los hombres son geniales y agresivos y toman riesgos",
pero al final no es sobre hombres y mujeres.
Es una narrativa diferente.
Es sobre una gente que se siente emocionada y motivada
y está educada para manejar sus finanzas
frente a aquellos que no lo están.
Si cambian la conversación sobre los hombres y las mujeres
a lo que realmente hay bajo la superficie
probablemente dejarán de ser tan condescendiente con las mujeres
y podrán empezar a atender a los hombres
que en realidad son tímidos al administrar sus finanzas.
Les dejaré con un ejemplo más.
Si retrocedo a las mujeres que hacían deporte al principio,
una de las cosas fascinantes que encontramos en diferentes países,
estudiando ropa deportiva,
es que si la persona es competitiva
y está en plena acción,
las necesidades no son diferentes entre hombres y mujeres.
Un atleta es un atleta.
No importa si eres hombre o mujer, viejo o joven,
eres un atleta,
y en plena acción, y competición extrema,
necesitas llevar lo que funciona para tí.
Las mujeres que juegan fútbol tienen mucho en común con sus homólogos.
Fuera del campo, esto no importa.
Fuera del campo, pueden ir a la moda, estar en otras cosas,
pero en el campo, las necesidades no son diferentes.
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos de las categorías donde descubrimos
que el género no es el mejor lugar adonde acudir,
y en realidad el argumento es
que en este punto, ni siquiera es una presión feminista,
es solo que nos acostumbramos.
Nos acostumbramos a usar el género,
y es importante para nosotros empezar a encontrar maneras
de medir otras cosas sobre los consumidores
para que no volvamos al género.
No soy ingenua,
y sé que todavía va a ser apetecible
y habrá cierta facilidad para usar el género,
pero al menos esto garantiza una conversación.
En su negocio, deben preguntarse,
¿es esta realmente la mejor forma para que crecer?
Si Uds. son como yo, una persona de negocios,
que están constantemente preocupados sobre su papel
en las discusiones sociales más amplias,
si están prestando atención a su negocio y escuchan cosas como:
"Oh, mi objetivo son las mujeres, son los hombres,
esto va para chicas jóvenes, para chicos jóvenes",
cuando es esa conversación de género,
a no ser que trabajen
en una categoría de producto de género muy, muy específica,
tómenlo como una señal de alarma
porque si continúan teniendo esas conversaciones,
continuarán perpetuando los estereotipos
y harán que la gente piense que los hombres y las mujeres son diferentes.
Como esto es un negocio, y manejamos un negocio,
y queremos hacerlo crecer,
al menos desafíen su propio instinto de usar el género,
porque las estadísticas dicen que no están escogiendo la mejor variable
para dirigir su producto o servicio.
El crecimiento no es nada fácil.
¿Qué les hace pensar que lograrán crecer
al entrar en el mercado usando una perspectvia tan obsoleta como el género?
Dejemos de hacer lo que es fácil y hagamos lo correcto.
A estas alturas, no es solo por nuestros negocios, es por la sociedad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)